hello welcome to zero playing nope no no
way i'm pronouncing this scott chick age
last I think this is actually somewhat
questionable move order well he just
gives me the barn okay how to believe
that this is any good so check you place
like instantly is this really a line so
my queen getting in trouble here may I
don't have many squares admittedly and I
have to save this teacher who kind of
sense I think I stole into that before
they don't have many squares I really
don't
what's happening to me what is happening
why isn't that why isn't that good for
white i think i just recently looked at
it something very similar at least and i
don't see how I save my queen he
threatening looks the aid and a six
maybe a six shutting down the Queen I
think I stumbled into this before
confusing the lines I think after a six
my queen is strapped yep and he found it
which is not rocket science admittedly
you can somehow continue this probably
not it's just the Queen great so queen
bee three is bad in this position I
don't believe this really weird
yeah I'm a queen down yeah for rockins
minor piece and he also has the better
coordination
I think I stumbled into exactly the same
thing before somehow i have this
recollection of my queen getting trapped
like that
okay white resides I've had enough so
why is that working why is that working
and I must confuse something what am i
confusing this with there is a
particular line with where queen bee
three is pretty strong I just want to
understand what I'm confusing this with
you played this this
97 yes take sticks when this what do I
have to go queen bee three immediately
here I think then you can't play that in
any case yeah because check here Bishop
d7 as possible it is it it's like that
is six and queen bee three should be
good for white and he just ignores this
hmm Wow of course I can just play d4 but
this is not not the point check so here
the engine gives 9 p-5 here now my III
was even a pretty bad try check this is
what the engine is giving and this move
assesses the whole thing is equal off to
be for Queen takes castles
yeah I just ignores the tear yeah but
this cannot be that great here provide
this has the reputation of being good
for white I'm just very sure about it
but I don't don't quite see how this
seems very interesting check man I the
way up late in the game it was a 2-1
joke III a 6 is very simple yeah it's
set the set still accept the position
that I'm thinking about or is it here
and now here that's not see fire totally
so confusing it with some other line but
I don't think so
it's not a six it's not Knight f6 it has
to be this they think it and the
immediate again isn't working so test to
be this this yeah this is very viable
this pawn sacrifice they have to check
that I didn't didn't look at this at
this pawn sec I think I only looked at
stuff where black is or this is what is
played normally in tournament chess they
play Queen B 6 cm Knight f6 some very
interesting yeah maybe in a blitz c'mere
me I should just should just play d4 and
and develop stuff it's at least easier
to play okay well thanks for watching